good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning pit this morning he texted me
he's like there's no key I'm like what
do you mean there's always a key for him
he said no the doorman says Ben took it
Ben uses our spare key like as his
personal key because he's so
irresponsible and like I'm Theo hasn't
been walked so now when I get home after
the chose to he'll be able to relieve
himself for the first time today which
is just not fair to Theo now seems low
mass how upset relieved himself but
speaking of Ben being selfish and
irresponsible we put up an episode on
our patreon last night of meat and then
just like we had done a Q&A a while back
we got so many questions that we weren't
able to get to they was all like dating
relationship kind of centric like living
together vibes so we did the second half
of the episode it's like 30 minutes just
answering the rest of the questions we
didn't get to so if you're not a patreon
member I don't know I've heard rave
reviews and I have people say it's the
best eight dollars they've ever spent
people say they don't know how to live
life without it the best part in today's
November first you could start a whole
new month I get all five new episodes
and you get access to all of the old
episodes from every month that's the
best part is there really are like some
gems in there like your birthday episode
oh yeah we give you so many blogs oh and
we did a blog yesterday yesterday which
was hilarious because we went shopping
for bridesmaids dresses for Olivia's
wedding and it was a complete and utter
failure we intended to make a
behind-the-scenes video of our
bridesmaids dress shopping process which
we did but it turned out to only be a
four-minute video because we had to
leave because it was so treacherous if
anyone from Saks Fifth Avenue corporate
is watching do better well we were like
about to do the vlog and we're like
wheat should we like talk about sacks
like maybe being like hashtag ad like
putting them in a positive light and we
couldn't have put positive we couldn't
have put Sachs in a positive light if we
tried and we did it was so terrible
first of all like now I know why
brick-and-mortar stores go out and I
don't even feel sad about it anymore
because like do better but then their
Nets doing better you have to do better
no we literally went in there like ready
to buy dress he's gonna spend almost
four figures like that's how much I need
a dress yeah if need be like you would
have we buy at that a dress that was so
beautiful flattering maybe look so
skinny and tan like I would have I would
have spent $700 yes we literally went
there with only our wallets ready today
I must spend money
fancy dresses for the three of us and we
just could not get arrested like we're
walking around every for pulling dresses
people are like pretending to help they
take our dresses I'll start a fitting
room we're quick New Yorkers and this is
a New York store we're ready for our
fitting room in a few minutes we both
love our dresses we have no fitting room
our dress suits our dresses are just
sitting in the back oh my god it was so
neat a pirate sleeve literally going
back by the way the selection like that
was not the level attacks with Grandma
like Grandma season no really like prom
dress season like really Sherri Hill
vibes and like it's just like that's not
what if I want to Cherry Hill vibe so
what if I went to show the hill like if
I wanted a glamorous old lady that's why
I went to Saks right and you did you got
old lady but you did not get the glamour
and talk about not being inclusive but I
just want to say I narrow down two dress
sizes like I'm back to the normal level
like adult sizes and I I couldn't she
pulled the shoe oh for suppose she came
to the dressing room with like four
dresses she's like here are all of the
dresses in your sizes in the whole store
she's like she basically to come to the
entire store for a piece of fabric to
fit my ass and I'm like oh thanks and
they were for of like some of the
ugliest dresses and look my size is like
very average now and I just feel like we
get as women we could do better no but
then on the other hand we were asking
for one dress in a multitude of sizes oh
yeah and she brought out Jackie tried on
a dress that we all really liked and
since we have to wear the same color
we're like people all wear the same
dress yeah it's like Sisterhood of the
Traveling dress so they asked for three
dresses in different sizes and she was
like oh the zero and gave it right to
Claudia so it's very it was it was a
very confusing also kept calling me the
mom I think she thought I was Jackie and
Mario's mom zero amazing about my zero
for the mom yeah
also um also none of em fat zero
oh right yeah yeah no definitely never
never never asked her zero it was just
not a premium experience we didn't get
anything was just so disappointing
because I have now ordered every [ __ ]
bridesmaid's dress that comes in a wine
Amer Lowe from Kleinfeld Nordstrom and
David's Bridal they were all so [ __ ]
terrible wait I ordered three dresses
from David's Bridal and they sent me six
three dresses that I didn't order in cut
in colors and sizes that I didn't ask
for well you know people are freaking
out about David's Bridal
because there's a rumor this sounds like
insider trading so are they public
whatever
whatever gonna text me broker just
kidding gonna go on Robin Hood - David
Spratt very good yeah uh there's a rumor
that David's Bridal is going out of
business and like people are worried
that their orders won't be fulfilled so
if you need a bridesmaid dress I want to
get my bridesmaids dress from David's
Bridal because I had so much success for
your wedding right Vera Wang does a
David's Bridal line that has a Miller
bride me for bridesmaids that has a
million styles and literally every color
you've ever heard of and they're so easy
like you're like they let you buy for
$15 a swatch of the material or the
fabric like it's really just like a
user-friendly interface thing you can
also like just go to go to the store try
on the dress in your size
find out what size you are order the
color that you need online like so for
my wedding
like all the bridesmaids pick the
dresses I did the order they came
literally in three days everyone loved
their dress fit color everything was
perfect for Olivia's wedding I'm like
damn this is gonna be so easy
i order three dresses and they were so
[ __ ] ugly yeah it's like sometimes
when you're just told exactly what you
need to do like the fact that we can get
a wine dress from anywhere in the world
is actually very difficult how much you
free if you tell me I can only get a
wine dress from revolve right like this
wine I'll make it happen I make it
happen
ya know it's like why now why'd this
wine there aren't enough rules and it's
annoying me
no it you really need structure and I'm
I don't want I don't wanna be the one to
tell Olivia but like she doesn't have to
change her color
oh really I thought wine a burgundy was
gonna work for me and it's not it's it's
not no there's no dresses you know where
I looked Giovanni
cuz I figured they probably have good
chip yeah like a upgraded Sherri Hill
yes and they have like three dresses and
wine and I really want something long
sleeves do you member an Angelina Jolie
went to the Oscars and she wore emerald
green a sequin long-sleeve dress mm-hmm
and I'd like a little Center of the ways
that's really the silhouette I'm going
for we should go to Macy's mmm I can't I
I can't go to Macy's and it smelled
really bad but I had such success I got
two designer dresses one that I wore
this weekend
it's Jil Sander and like I went to pay
for them like I really needed to back
tight dresses so I was willing to pay
the piper
and they were just like honey they were
just like the prices just kept getting
slashed it was like they were free
that's what they do at Lord and Taylor I
can't go to Macy's for so money said
Lord and Taylor before they close I know
they don't we've made dresses every time
Heather make mad
on the toast she's like I'm going to
Lord and tell her for me she's obsessed
with it when she cheated yes oh my god
like she's somebody did you see when she
did - she did three she did a new one
last night yeah and she was like oh did
you stop by Leslie's I see she's still
hitting at stubborn kandi sad she's so
[ __ ] funny I'm like original and
creative and the only person who's more
in love with her than me is the points
guy and I don't even think he's ever met
her well we should make it happen here
on the toast it's gonna happen at the
points guy Awards which you're going to
by the way right yes it's a vase - quiet
I - we need a dress for that there's so
many things I need two dresses for today
I'm going to be lzma Awards I'm going to
sue Bloomingdale's
um I've started only go to
Bloomingdale's for the personal shopping
and I used to think that personal
shopping was only for rich people
because I thought you had to pay for the
appointment and like however long you
see end but you know you don't the the
personal shopper works off of
commissions so it's like and every time
I go I really do buy a million things
and like a good statement pieces and I'm
the best woman Lisa who is a toaster and
she'll really appreciate being called
out because she listens to the toast
until going today for CMA Awards I think
I might go for a jumpsuit kind of look
maybe I'll go with you except my concern
with not concerned about with personal
shoppers is like there's no way to
describe what my style is and I feel
like I I have like good like I can pick
really well for myself and someone else
can't do a better job picking than I can
so they know the inventory better than I
can so if I can tell them what the Hat
things I want to focus on the colors
that I like maybe yes that is true
no one can pick better than than you but
like I find that if I have to walk the
floor on a big store and go Amelia I'm
so exhausted by the time I have to try
things on even if it looks good I'm like
I have time to wait in line yeah so it's
like a the trek the physical treachery
of shopping is very real you shop till
you drop
yes and if you go personal shopping to
the same person more than once like they
start to understand your vibe like
that's their job I need a personal
shopper who like is familiar with my
Instagram okay and like wouldn't know my
first time I met Lisa was for The Today
Show and I was scrambling because I got
booked too literally three hours before
and she started pulling out like berets
and scarfs and beads and I was like
homegirl Lisa this is not working for me
because she is like so small and frail
and like into fashion and like she may
look good in that and luckily
this is not working and I obviously
ended up in like a dark navy blue blazer
black jeans and like a white blouse and
she started to understand my more
loose-fitting dark colors need sleeves
vibe and now every time I go it's like
we're learning more about each other now
I've been back like five times and like
every time I go when she pulls her hands
she I wouldn't have known that like
Halston heritage is my brand if it
weren't for Lisa the jumpsuit that I
wore to the life of the gift of life
gala where I met him was from Halston
heritage and it was on sale and it was
literally $20 Wow maybe I should go with
you because we need to be snatched as
hell especially because I'm not gonna
say what it is because you know once you
say something they always have a way of
unraveling like our plan at the CMA
Awards which if you if you're a new
toaster last year at the CMA Awards we
did our red carpet show it was an
unbelievable [ __ ] show in the most
incredible way it was seriously to date
the hardest I've ever worked in the most
premium content I've ever created the
performance of a lifetime the
performance of a lifetime see the
hardest I've ever worked to date is Kam
toast
Oh oh my god of course because that was
three days ago words but this year we're
obviously gonna be back bigger and
better than ever and there's a very
strong chance that we are going to be
partnering partnering with a very
legitimate media company and we're
you're gonna be seeing us okay that's
all I'm just right and the thing is is
that even if that doesn't pan out we're
still be still there like with the
[ __ ] iPhones with the toast yeah and
it's gonna be amazing and if you haven't
seen our previous red carpet coverage in
are unfamiliar with our groundbreaking
work ask the toasters where to find it
and then they'll send you a link they'll
show you the way it was so funny and I
was actually when you apply for a press
credentials you have just like they
asked have you ever done red carpet
coverage before if so upload some
content so I had to go back and find the
link and honestly I went down a rabbit
hole for two hours because we were so
funny and so many jokes like that we
still talk about today originated on the
red carpet because we were like wow
because really like they put us at we
were nobodies back then like it was our
first red carpet they put us in a
premium spot every celebrity stuff I
asked all the publicists knew the brats
so like they came by like and we just
were like wow CAA respects that hell out
of the morning breath and now that's
something we use like all the time and
also the Karlie Kloss moment I were in
her vlog she did a vlog I know when I
left my I left my credentials back at
the where we were recording when we went
into the Awards which I thought was that
me the best part of the show and was
actually like the worst first cuz I
wanted to watch it on the
um I ran back to get my credentials then
I ran to go to our seats and I was
running I saw I was in her video so I
was like lol I literally have never
looked so short like it's crazy
specially next to her like next to her
and it's crazy that like Kim is that
short like I can't get over it I know
I'm like Kendall and Kendall is Carly
and they like they don't even look that
crazy next to each other totally it's so
underrated how short Kim is it's so
underrated like she doesn't carry
herself as a short person but we do um I
think the biggest lesson now we learned
it's like we must wear sensible shoes
Kim was wearing sensible shoes for the
CMA red card oh my god of course we took
our shoes off and we were running around
like kids with our socks like I'm gonna
wear literally like Olivia's platform
sneakers well I hope that cuz I'm gonna
need a heel but I can't stand for more
than ten men wear long pants ooh but I
haven't been able to find when I almost
ordered one from Aliexpress but like
I've never ordered something give me
their pantsuit like Hillary Clinton
Bobby yeah like like tailored pants suit
you're like a Diane Keaton vibe sure
she's always wearing a tuxedo she looks
amazing
yeah we're even like a Courtney vibe
okay in like a plea knee color she was
like Courtney was definitely sired by
Diane Keaton who is inspired by Hillary
Clinton no Diane Keaton is a starring in
the can see aficionado but also there's
a difference between like a pantsuit and
then like a pantsuit with a tailored
well that's a cocido okay I mean I want
to wear a plain e tuxedo applix IDO but
do you want a bell bottom or a tailored
look
I want to tailor it like so then you
have to wear heels [ __ ] now that I wear
granny heels maybe I can makes it it's a
long show and it's a lot of physicality
I was wearing like literally Steve
Madden hooker heels like I'm standing on
my feet there's a difference between a
saline grandmother heel and a Steve
Madden strappy sandal like there is a
world of difference well at the end of
our every interview with our talent at
the CMA Awards we asked them in one word
describe your morning breath and it was
funny but like now what would we do like
I can't even tell you how happy I am to
be not have that question anymore why it
was funny it was funny then but like it
was so close yet like I don't know that
parting I don't would you medium rare or
else I'm gonna wear the toast girls what
are you chose with what are you gonna
toast it with when you win a big CMA
well we'll have a full ball or work on
the wording yeah well and whatever they
say well give it to them oh yeah and
last time we literally got one bottle of
whiskey and we were like someone will
drink it it was gone every person took a
shot with that including us and like we
were so drunk we were because we
in that day and look was just a hard day
you know yeah I'm so excited
do you ever feel um like a piece of dirt
like a flaky crusty piece of dirt yes
now right now I think I watched my hair
last night I feel like a crusty and it
doesn't have to do with my hair it's
like you know when you just are putting
your makeup on and like it only takes to
some areas of your face oh do you know
yes but I haven't experienced that in a
while because I really feel like I've
been moisturizing and I know this is so
lame grandma vibes turning 26 next week
but not drinking does wonders for your
skin so I've been having like really
good skin as well and I switched to a
new I got like a PR package and I got
this face cream and I've been switching
to only cream based cleansers because I
have dry skin and I got the scent one
and I'm like oh this is cool and I tried
it and as I was doing it it was weird
because it's like a moisturizer and a
cleanser and a makeup remover I actually
bought one too I brought it for you no
and I'm not gonna say the bread cuz I'm
not gonna disparage a band a brand that
sends me good [ __ ] but like it was
horrible
and it can't help but think that like my
new terrible makeup face has something
to do with the cleanser that I used last
night well from where I'm sitting you
look great I just get yo great but thank
you for saying that and I got new
earrings from bauble bar I'm obsessed
with bauble bar you are yeah I don't
know I'm not like I I'm I'm not so into
jewelry that's like a fun fact about me
um and I'm recently like trying like now
that I have my ears parsed and
everything but it's hard for me to get
into like fun jewelry like I don't know
I've got my ears pierced when jewelry
and I didn't start wearing ornamental
jewelry libel until two years ago like
yes and now every time like on the
bachelorette party like every time I
hang out with girls who wear ornamental
jewelry I'm reinvigorated for my love of
ornamental jewelry yeah I mean and Alec
Danny and Kristen were wearing the
cutest earrings that's why I bought
these because I bought the earrings that
they both had from bauble bar and I just
also bought like another pair also like
for Miami for Olivia's Bachelorette like
I'm feeling like you like I was a pretty
little thing last night like ready to
stop so Jenna I didn't find anything for
the thought like for the thought that
I'm trying to be but I'm really excited
because I've never been like it to Miami
and do you know that I'm Fleming the
full itinerary and I'm packing it with
ratchetness from start to finish and you
better be down I will because like like
you mean like ship clubs it's not our
bills I mean I will pack my single so
also that's a great segue into so this
coming Thursday I will be your coming to
me and Charlotte which I added a second
show there's a couple tickets available
girl with no job comic
wait to see you all there the points
kites coming to that show so everyone
else to come because his headquarters is
in Charlotte so that morning I won't be
here masks are exactly that morning I
won't be here which I'm sad about
especially because Teresa Giudice is our
guest on Wednesday oh sorry
Wednesday Wednesday November 7 Teresa
Giudice is our guest I've been trying to
find the right co-host for the job and
actually I mean I found it and it wasn't
that hard joey camasta yeah I'm so
excited it's gonna be a very Jersey day
that's what I was going for I just went
like Jersey bye
you have to embrace like your inner Long
Island you accent happily happily and
joey camasta like comment in my
Instagram yesterday that he wants the
wigs that I wore as Courtney and like
it's yours and he sware it here yes but
you just worked so fast okay it's our
joy come outside come on good man sir
man one of the way because like the name
joey camasta just rolls up its Telos and
it just makes you want to talk pastor
enjoyed myself
yeah he's mercy lasting yeah I'm excited
I've never hosted with him before he's
one of the funniest people so then
Thursday I won't be back either but out
together and then premium of course
Friday I'm back and we're doing a show
right before we jet off to Miami for
Olivia's bachelorette party and I've
literally planned the trip of a lifetime
ready Friday night 11:00 strip club
because like I've never been do you know
I've never been to Miami like a giant
like driving down Lincoln having you
like to get from one place to another
like I've never been out of Miami I've
never stayed in Miami
isn't that weird Mima I've been to
Florida 500 times like all we did
growing rice go to Fargo Raton Fort
Lauderdale Palm Beach never been to
Miami that's so weird
yes so I want the full after you got
that weird cuz I really have never been
in to Miami like for vacation until I
met Ben and Ben is obsessed with Miami
so yeah I won't be too now no big you
would [ __ ] you're gonna hate it
I know but it's perfect for two three
days that's what we're gonna do we'll
make me never want to go to Miami very
and the beach is great and I don't think
its peak season so like it won't be
inundated with people but I like can't
go back to Miami because last year for
New Year's me and Ben decided to go for
a year and we both got so much time off
work that we went like literally two
weeks before New Year's and we literally
overdid it to the nth degree and by the
time New Year's rolled around we weren't
even
I woke up after New Year's morning and
we were supposed to fly home on the
second and I got us on a plane the first
this is a pattern with you you know what
it is
and I can't help but think about all the
money I would have saved if I only
booked to the right flights home every
time I go to LA I get cabin fever and
get on the red-eye because I'm you
supposed to leave the next morning I'm
like now let me just leave that in the
night before I always changed my flight
which is why I'm so excited to reach the
Platinum adalian level in Delta which
I'm going to reach very soon because
then they let you move your flights much
more flexibility has to be sent out to
people who can like help us with South I
know what does anyone work for you at
blue I need to make a call I am in need
of just like a Delta go-to person and
honestly I used to have one and I bother
her too much and now she hates me so if
you work at Delta and you have power to
like move seats move flights upgrade see
it's like please hit me off more so
you'd move flights without change pieces
all I'm looking for cancel a flight that
I have this weekend JetBlue without a
change fee that would be really helpful
I don't know if I'm going to call yet
anymore why has changed I mean it's TBD
why do you want to see wicked yes I was
sick you book your tickets yeah no okay
just hold off okay I want to see wicked
I kind of Ben's never seen wicked
because that was obviously showing him
the ariana grande thing because he
appreciates a good talent and I thought
he would appreciate it and I think I
thought he liked like show tunes I guess
he doesn't I nice if you know I've never
seen wicked I was like what I didn't
grow up in New York and never see wicked
that's like never seeing The Lion King
and his mom loves Broadway like they're
always going to shows so I was just like
shocked to find that out so we have to
we have to right that wrong yeah I'll
see one no something crazy
yeah it's November it's not crazy that
is crazy it's my birth month my
birthday's in less than a week and like
it's gotta mean less than a week it's
five days five days but it's like so
crazy because everyone's like counting
down until November 6 and so am i but
like for completely different reasons
let hell escape legit Bay right how
[ __ ] like lame is that for me so lame
what a great opportunity to tell
everyone to vote - right to vote I think
it's too late to register but get out
only in New York cuz you know one time
the first time I ever voted
well actually the first time I ever
voted was when I was in NYU and they
made it so easy for you if you were
living in the dorm and I got a letter
literally a year later that my um ballad
was never cast because captain said
captain sandy oh my god hurricane sandy
hurricane sandy like [ __ ]
the mail and like a bunch of letters I
mean ballads never got said is that
crazy that's crazy that and then the
captain said I know the number one
reference then they hit after that I
voted but I wasn't registered and I got
went to the table I'm like I'm not
registered can I vote and she's like
yeah sure I'm like oh this look at that
making it so easy for us I got a letter
like a month later hey you're okay the
thing was never cast you're not really
registered I'm like oh that's so
interesting that I'm not really
registered yet I've gotten called for
jury duty that's interesting I find that
interesting I'm intrigued
the interesting fact because what they
don't tell you is well you should 1000%
register to vote and it's only positive
there is one small negative and it's
that now you are in the running for a
jury duty explain to me how I wasn't
eligible to vote yet I was eligible to
be a civil servant and complete my civil
server - that makes you think you know
what corruption runs deep it's
interesting it's interesting it's
definitely interesting but now you're in
a you're in a place where you can vote I
think we'll find out we'll find that on
Tuesday well everyone seriously should
vote I got an email about it yesterday
um you know what I should do the right
thing hold on
it was like just one of those like in
fact artisan um companies reaching out
about like just using like talking about
on the chose give me one second hold on
okay vote it does it just tell you how
to vote in your area it's like up rocks
Oh elements and rock the boat I gotta go
up fluence is teaming up with rock to
vote a nonpartisan organization that is
working with influencers to spread the
word about registering to vote through
their brands for democracy stirred about
okay yeah sorry like try if you can get
tricked by that Kevin Kahn anything like
it's probably lost for you but whatever
no but maybe it's not because if you're
not clicking that like maybe you have
your priorities in order
yeah something that everyone should have
their priorities in order because that's
just how I want to live my life and
honestly I guess I already for me
yesterday's episode was so funny like I
literally spent the entire day looking
at and making content of Snitch as Chris
snitch as Chris was truly like the
cherry tomato it was a top of my year it
was the greatest show it was the great
show like she just cinched the vote for
us and it was really hard because last
year unintentionally like we delivered
we
[ __ ] like we by the way we literally
bought the wigs the day of we were just
like you're supposed to be holding Kathy
and then we realize we look like each
other oh yeah yeah like we really just
didn't really think it through and it
was just like a half-assed thing like
we're like you put on eyebrows and I
like yeah there was a makeup team there
otherwise I would have worn my own
eyebrows in a brown wig yeah look man I
was thinkin you bring me a co sweater
and you actually remember to and we
ended up being so funny that like it was
actually like intimidating to do it
Halloween this year because like we
could never be as funny as we were last
year and last year will forever be
iconic but I was worried this year that
we wouldn't have that same moment I know
you that you were and Snitch really just
outdid herself she really didn't know
but also snitch she did a job well done
yesterday like and since then I've been
calling everyone a [ __ ] lunatic I'm
happy for you
on our patreon episode with Ben I did
this whole thing you should watch it oh
I bet he is he is a [ __ ] lunatic so
it was fun okay well are you ready for
the fast eye stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
I guess well if you wanted to continue
to talk about the Kardashians here we
use of course I do of course and
yesterday's episode and yes sir they
gave us so much to work with they really
didn't oh they really like show up for
Halloween I mean really all celebrities
do because it's like they're one can't
tie me you're like two trying to get
your open people right send from heaven
the kardashian-jenner sisters dress up
as Victoria's Secret Angels for
Halloween we have some photos for you in
case you live under a rock
but Kim Kourtney and Khloe Kendall and
Kylie teamed up for the family's most
epic sister Halloween costume to date in
photos released by the Daily Mail and on
the sisters Instagram so yeah the
sisters are seen channeling their aunt
or Victoria Secret Angels while wearing
sexy white lingerie looks massive angel
wings supplied by Victoria Secret
themselves and crystal encrusted high
heels as they started in unison for the
camera before heading to a Halloween
party
Kim tweeted a behind-the-scenes photo of
her look writing thank-you to a
Victoria's Secret for sending us actual
runway looks and real wings to borrow
for the night oMG a dream come true
got to be a Victoria's Secret Angel for
the night and Kendall got good practice
lol okay so many thoughts here so many
thoughts was this sponsor okay 100% I've
had the same one hundred percent Ottawa
sponsor because why would Kim Kardashian
and Kylie and the rest of the sisters
who have 60 million followers tag
and if it's not paid for and the timing
is that the Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show is happening in New York on
Thursday so this would be PR for the
show a week from today so I did a little
digging and Jezebel had the same
question as us
well that's the first time I've ever had
anything in common with Jezebel right
the Kardashians say they weren't paid
for their brand official Victoria's
Secret Halloween costumes The Hollywood
Reporter dug a little deeper and a
representative for the Kardashians told
them that quote it was not a paid
sponsorship the girls did it just for
fun but then thr points out that a press
release put out by the Tauri secret
suggests this is maybe a if not paid
more official arrangement than the
Kardashians let on right quote the
sisters are clad in wings from the Tory
Secret Fashion Show runway and Kylie can
be seen in the bodysuit by Candice swamp
Swan pole who she did tag wore during
the 2015 Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
the release read in part and then linked
to all the merchandise the family is
wearing in their Instagram post if you
go to Victoria's Secret they took all
the pictures and they were like Lincoln
bio to shop the look so there they're
profiting Kim and Kendall both thank
Victoria's Secret in their posts of the
night which suggests they borrowed the
wings and is a valid this grows her
disclosure under FTC rules and you have
to disclose that you borrowed it quote
the FTC's endorsement guides provide if
there is a material connection between
an endorser and an advertiser in other
words a connection that might affect the
weight or credibility that consumers
give the endorsement that connection
should be clearly and conspicuously
disclosed unless it is already clear
from the context of the communication
FTC rules however my thought is they
borrow clothes all the time they don't
tag and thank the brand so I don't know
if they Victoria's Secret paid them to
wear these costumes but this might be
the first step in a larger collaboration
so best mean the two entity as someone
who's like worked with a brand before
it's like not everything you do for the
brand is paid because you just like
wanna foster or good relationships like
sometimes you'll throw in like an extra
whatever because like you like the brand
and you just want to like have good
rapport so I don't necessarily see
regulations if this was an ad they would
have done hashtag ad and it still would
have been popping as hell so while I
don't think there was a necessary
exchange of like post this for X amount
of money
there's definitely something larger
brewing and this is just the Kris Jenner
business model agreed and we got premium
content they got premium content it's a
win all around and someone somewhere
making money yeah and by the way that's
not to say that they're not getting some
sort of cut of whatever profits Victoria
Secrets gonna make off of all their
sales you know yeah yeah which after
everyone splits it is not that much but
I mean who knows
I was so living for this look Kim looked
like 2010 Kim it's crazy how she looks
this like you think she looks so
different but all she has to do is part
her hair down the middle to the long
beach she wave and stand like this and
smile and all of a sudden like she's
running she tassel like and that's
exactly what Mario captioned he was like
we went for 2010 glam oh they knew that
she you know what I really should have
reports on her down the middle and if
she does this with that long terrible
straightener and it's that Beach way
that that like frames her face yeah oh
my god and I guess she does like a
lighter eyeshadow like I don't know what
it is but I was loving it and it just
made me realize wow we really think
they've changed so much and they have
hmm but they also haven't and they were
looking at these oh [ __ ] snatch I
just won every single one of them Chloe
I know looked in credit and she's the
one who said the baby most recently baby
most recently and has always had like
the most heart like the Jenners just our
athletes yes they're in theory builds
came like this is her whole career is
her body yes Chloe like has always had
the hardest time losing weight anyways
revenge body yeah and she looked so
incredible so it was really like just
like evaluating everyone's outfits and
their wings and like Courtney had the
worst wings they were like a stringy and
like like they will pick twigs someone
commented do you think Courtney had the
most interesting wings because she's the
least interesting to look at no they
were the weirdest wings and I just think
it's weird that she would participate in
something like this cuz you know that's
just like not her priority like this is
what you have to do to get like right
that's and by the way no like this is
the exact culmination of what in the
season she's saying is not her priority
no but maybe Bobby said things have
changed since she broke up with Eunice
and but are the oh no they're not back
together
no um maybe there's a good payday also
she was wearing like a bumpit situation
she was looking like 2010 Courtney they
all looked so young Kendall looked
amazing and this is just like it's so
unfair because like Kendall as long as
Kendall wants to be in the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show she can be given who
she is but also now like this huge
partnership and it's like she's like
these girls are supposed to be competing
with Kendall like these girls were
the industry for so long like haven't
eaten a cob in 22 years like it's like
it's still not even fair
you know agreed and Kendall doesn't even
like realize she's like she in her
interviews like I've worked so hard like
blah blah blah black my family didn't
get me anywhere I'm saying you've
definitely worked hard and and you tried
to distance yourself from your family
but like if you grew up like on a farm
in Kentucky would you be really where
would you be
and I have this like terrible love-hate
relationship with Victoria Secret
because a lot of the times like they're
super in tune with what's necessary
they're with their shows like they're
them having Taylor Swift and Fall Out
Boy like that was the greatest thing of
all time and they do so much premium
[ __ ] but then like I really start to
hate them for so many reasons because
like as a brand they're not inclusive
and I can't believe they really haven't
had a Ashley Graham walk in their show
yet like come on come on but I feel like
them partnering with the Kardashian is a
step in the right direction step in the
right direction and if they are smart
this is like what they'll put forth like
the Kardashians will be on their
campaigns but the Kardashians do have my
Calvin's and like is that not a conflict
to underwear like company no they're so
different but that's a good point yeah
they're you know but like Victoria's
Secret is this American brand like it's
really it's ever any mall whether you're
in the East Coast the West Coast the
Midwest like you are gonna find a
Victoria's Secret and like the average
woman looks nothing like a Victoria's
Secret model so we find it really like
so shocking that they haven't had Ashley
Graham yet and like good for her for
like hating them publicly cuz like they
should or [ __ ] the most deserving of
work in the entire world
it's Crowe Lawrence because she is the
most amazing body and she works so hard
and like nobody cares I'm setting
Claudia I care I care but I have this
love/hate relationship with them because
like Ivan literally I haven't bought a
bra from Victoria's Secret in years
literally since like I was taking to
Victoria's Secret on a camp trip to the
mall right and you like just think it's
the only place to buy bras like growing
up cuz res bras right and it's like
they're everywhere so why not no but
nowadays there are so many like
different places that are like boobs are
not a one-size-fits-all thing like you
start talking to the two biggest busty
this breasted women our whole family
like the size boobs in our family is
double D and and they're not
proportional right
and they're Jewish you know they sag a
little like COD right so like Victoria's
Secret fits none of my knees I remember
last time I wore Victoria's Secret bra
was wear and I was also wearing like
Hanes me neck shirts and like it's
called for boob when you have like four
yep and like the cups have cups right
but there's this company third love
where like you do this whole fit profile
online like you take us by the ways that
is my favorite thing
oh you're selling you're ordering a
product and they make you fill out like
a survey because like how do you know
what I like you think it's not like
everyone wants to see whatever like I
did it with a mattress and I loved it
like I loved the personalized questions
it really feels like they're listening
and that they care yeah or at least that
whatever I'm gonna get is good and like
they in this survey they asked you what
size you're wearing now and then how it
fits you like do you have overhang do
you have like cups that pop out right
what are the shillings what are the
shape of your breasts here drop
something that I never thought about
there were all these different like
breast shapes and I was like oh that's
me yeah you know no and it was like and
then they tell you write a cartoon porn
like the Playboy book exactly home to
our patreon and then they tell you what
your bra size is and if you've been
wearing like the right size all this
time yeah I found out that I actually
had been wearing the right size for the
past few years but now I got a bra from
third love like so they sent me you got
to choose like what kind of bra you want
they have like such nice bras and it
feels so good there's like no tags
there's no so I've been wearing the
wrong cup size and the wrong number do
you know any yeah the wrong cup size is
smaller and my width is obviously bigger
than I anticipated and they're literally
my favorite part is that they don't have
tags yeah it's like the the tag is just
written on the actual on the clasp so
like when I always get the easiest
[ __ ] back itches because of the tag
it's the worst no it's the most
comfortable bra that you'll ever wear
and like bras are so important to our
everyday life your posture your poo but
like you I wear a bra more than I wear
underwear nobody without it and in the
store yesterday I tried on a dress that
I don't really like and the saleswoman
she was like you have to lift up your
bra straps and she tied my bra straps so
tight and my boobs were a different I
was a different person they were
standing up on their own it was the
craziest thing like that's just a
testament to how like the right bra
the right fit like literally can change
your posture change your body change
everything about it means your body
shape and obviously because we're
generous as [ __ ] we have a coat for you
we have a code for you
so third love knows there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they're
offering our listeners 15% off 15% off
your first order go to third love calm
slash morning toast now to find your
perfect fitting bra and get 15% off your
first purchase
that's third love comm slash morning
toast for 15% off today take the quiz
you'll be like so pleased with how much
detail they they give and that you'll
know that your bra is the right bra for
you
I like really annoyed by the fact that
the color of my jeans and the color of
my shirt are like two different blacks I
guess I've worn these jeans so much that
they're like now charcoal oh yeah
they're like light wash and I can see it
on the lives I didn't it's not as stark
on the line no it's bad also I'm falling
into fall today you're falling into fall
and honestly I'm a little upset of you
why you to say anything about my shoes
oh my god there were so many times I was
gonna segue into them like when you went
when you were talking about I literally
bought them for you know like every time
I was going to talk about them you
hadn't finished what you're up to right
but when you're talking about like your
vibe for personal shopping and like all
day look at your shoes no I know
lettuce tells you everything you need to
know about Claudia as a woman like she's
stylish she's American and she's
comfortable she's a little granny yeah
but like I'm really into loafers these
girls friend she's rich oh yeah first
actually no I got them at second and I'm
really into loafers these days I think
that it along eights my legs and the
jeans and it's just more comfortable and
I love a backless loafer because I don't
worry about getting blisters and I just
really like these shoes I need a loafer
I've been looking for a loafer for so
long and you know what I'm thinking for
my birthday I'm gonna buy myself
something like really nice oh I don't
know what it is yet and I know maybe it
should be like Gucci bag Gucci bag Gucci
bag and it might be I'm definitely not
for another not for another four minutes
yeah we can't do ad into math um I think
I'm gonna go to be cheap maybe I'll buy
a Gucci bag Gucci bag dude you bag maybe
I'll buy loafers because that's what I
actually really need night I've been
wanting Gucci loafers for a long time
and I think I choose yourself I've
earned it totally but then it gets me
like so annoying because it's okay you
want to splurge but like if you want to
get you over so you can get a good pair
like online not at Gucci store like for
the same quad
but just like better price it then look
far-fetched like there's so many
websites that just like you get the real
thing it's just like cheaper for super I
bet you also don't have that like
birthdays experience of going up so the
story that we wanted you during the day
for your birthday shopping I can move it
I could shop a little okay we should
also like we have to vote oh my god
right oh wait so I have a new address
you didn't know I'm you're still
registered in the same place so we'll
vote we'll shop we'll eat so definitely
yeah did you make reservations yes of
course it's on your calendar was it the
place by my house that I told you about
yes okay you told me about that we've
been yeah I know but like you asked me
if what I thought when I confirmed that
we should go there yeah you had positive
thought yeah yeah any positive thoughts
all the time it's ready on your calendar
I sent to Google invite to everyone
because um I don't want anyone like no
cup like yeah not that anyone we make
plans for my birthday evening no no
actually but they didn't want me to come
to Charlotte tonight before to do a show
and I said absolutely not I have a very
important dinner with a very important
business co-worker with a very important
business woman look at her shoes oh my
gosh cuffs we're just a couple of
business women's shoes tonight no no you
are so business it but you're definitely
breaking them in okay our second story
Wow it's 1109 we're only on our second
story is also about Victoria's Secret
because the Victoria's Secret fashion
shows performers have been announced and
then I also want to talk about the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show for a
second even though we already talked
about it they finally announced the
show's musical performers this morning
please welcome to the V s fashion show
stage Shawn Mendes the chainsmokers
Halsey Kelsea Ballerini Rita Ora bebe
Rexha and the struts it's one of the
most extensive performer lineup show has
ever had right here am I see here's my
thoughts chainsmokers are performing
with Kelsea Ballerini
oh yeah the other three of them out Rita
Ora and bebe Rexha like PXA here for my
show or it does have a new song that
like snitch listen I have to say
something like for the most part I think
they're trying to make up for the fact
that last year in Shanghai due to some
like crazy embargoes like Katy Perry and
a bunch of other people weren't allowed
in the cut in the country so that she
wasn't able to perform and now they're
like really trying to step up their game
and like be back and for so many reasons
that we try to secret show in my mind is
cancelled but the one thing that like
will keep me like watching on YouTube
the performances because they always
have a good like I come on the
performances so read me again who was
the first one Shawn Mendes very in tune
with what's necessary very similar like
when Justin Bieber when he was like this
young guy and all the girls loved him he
was like a little too young but it was
wonderful and he had a great voice
Shimon is this such a good performer if
he doesn't sing in my blood and they
don't do something about like parents
dinner air like I'll be upset because I
would be a missed opportunity but a +
choice I have too much choice and like
maybe he'll get some tail while he's
there 100% even though you know what we
know but also I'm like when you when you
said his name first I'm like oh wow
they're gonna kill it then keep going to
chainsmokers Halsey Kelsey Valerie
anyone you just have to change muggers I
was like they don't even perform like I
think it'll be with Kelsea Ballerini
she's gonna perform one of her country
songs no and the two songs that Kelsea
Ballerini
and Halsey are on also one of the
chainsmokers is on he doesn't sing on
many songs he only sings I'm closer with
Halsey and feeling whatever whatever
it's called with Kelsea Ballerini which
is literally their it a song about time
you listen to her husband's album we're
gonna happen of course I have there is
once the album is amazing amazing one
song on the album that is currently like
changing my life
it's called we dream okay and there's
like a children's choir in the beginning
I gotta love a choir he has a song about
Kelsey called America huh
unreal 11 a lotta make-a-wish good you
better get your bag got your bag get you
baggage or completions and wicked on
Broadway with ariana grande end up
Cameron oh god I didn't write before
turn 1112 I was thinking that Ariana
Grande has to play idina menzel
in wicked and we're even for a wicked
live John Cameron is a perfect choice
and you know they were in hairspray
together so there's a the friendship
yeah and they follow each other ok so we
keep going because then I was like after
Shawn Mendes I'm like ok trains burgers
are fine with Halsey and Kelsea
Ballerini definitely here for here for
it Rita Ora one of the worst decisions
probably ever by any company in the last
20 years
Rita Ora is not a singer sorry you have
Rita Ora and bebe Rexha supersets either
of them they're the same person and bebe
Rexha is better at being read
then read auras agreed so it just seems
redundant have to redirect says there
and honestly if bebe Rexha is there
where's Florida Georgia line what is she
gonna sit I don't know you know they
should have had instead of the third one
to this trike actually there's four of
them in this trifecta Rita Ora bebe
Rexha Charli XCX to Aleppo should have
been there instead of both of these
people honestly if they had done like
what they used to do would like with
just two performances it should have
been Shawn Mendes and dua Lippa
because to Allah belongs are all like
female bat-like anthem right and they're
like strut worthy yeah and you know that
she's on a song uh Andrea Bocelli's
knooow but I saw it's good I didn't hear
now that I think she had like hey I
don't know her voice that well but I
wouldn't like think she's one of like
she's not Andrea Bocelli vocalist of our
generation like she held her own
okay good first and then the last one is
the struts which is a rock band I'm sure
you've never heard of I actually know a
few of their songs because when I was
working at iHeartRadio like I heard them
playing somewhere and then Isis Sam did
and I was into them and they're they're
cool rock band and that was like when
they just forgot boy yes Fall Out Boy
like it's not one you would think would
be good for like in the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show but they performs
one of their songs with Taylor Swift and
it was when they had their comeback and
they released two amazing songs and like
I was so here for it so I'm open to
changing my mind but I can't get past
the Rita Ora of it all and I'm BB Rex's
literal number one fan and I don't think
she's ready for this opportunity like I
don't think I think the chainsmokers is
good I think Shawn Mendes is amazing and
I think they could have done better if
they were gonna cast more people I have
an amazing idea for what they should
have done they should have had I don't
know why I locked my iPad like this is
gonna end the show it's such a good idea
and now the shows that are live streams
gonna go out they should have had Panic
at the Disco performing the greatest
show which is that what they're doing on
greatest showmen reimagined and then had
a whole circus circus themed moment I
couldn't agree more and this is the
greatest show because that fits two
needs it doesn't necessarily need to be
panic at the disco like no but they're
doing it on greatest showmen reimagines
totally it could have been it but
there's a lot of people on greatest
showmen reimagine like I'm not married
to the panic at the disco idea that you
throw your marriage to create a showman
because a it's a theme which are always
looking for new winter wonderland how
many times can you do like summer in
Paris
jungle yeah so it's a theme you know
what I mean when to whatever and there's
always yeah there's always I mean
there's a million songs from the
soundtrack that are popular
and that everyone would like and know
and want to see the performs live but
the green show would be like like bang
bang bang bang ladies and gents this is
the moment you've waited for are we
pentatonix oh my god pentatonix in
marinara's [ __ ] phenomenal
[ __ ] fan what is song choice what a
song choice they okay so pentatonix
released a Christmas album most of which
I'm completely uninterested in listening
to because I'm still sitting this
morning to the mayor and Marta Swan and
accidentally listened to some of the
songs afterwards and they're just not
for me but because they're much more of
like a backup vocalist acapella by but
they need a singer and Maren Morris is
the singer and she sings you will when
you believe from the Prince of Egypt
which was originally done by Whitney
Houston Mariah Carey and Meryn redid it
and oh my god her voice sounds so
amazing and I love her so much because
she put a YouTube she put a video on her
Instagram story a couple days ago
overlaying the song and an iPhone video
she took while while she was recording
in the studio kind of just to prove that
like yes these are my vocals like I'm
not auto-tune like everyone else and she
seamlessly goes in the clip to the
iTunes in the clip to it sounds exactly
the same
Wow it's a craziest thing that's super
cool I felt I really sell video on
YouTube also it is November 1st which
means that the holiday season is
officially upon us and we went to Ben
Dale's yesterday to really get into the
holiday spirit and to you know really
take advantage of them going out of
business and nothing was on sale and I
was so disappointed and low price for
everything I bought I kept picking up
things and like was about to check out
and literally black people didn't want
to buy anything but I saw this keychain
that I knew Ben's mom would really like
and literally $75 for a couch and I'm
like what now I know made the store
banana business like going to Saks and
Bendel's yesterday really made me
realize like I used to be sad about like
all these stores going out of business
but like there's no store more deserving
to write a business and someone who
sells a keychain for something about
dollars no not even a brand name and
there's no store more worthy of coming
up then revolve and so into yep like on
Ana except radicalizing right they'll
figure it out they'll figure it out on a
product level on a marketing level like
they know what they're doing and like
their that's the reason why people are
shopping revolve instead of Saks how
come I would like but we're Bob needs a
store now I still like to go shopping
yeah and like revolves like I feel like
stores or so traditional where it's like
if you haven't been in business for X
amount of years and you don't have X
amount of sales you can't get into our
store where it's like revolve
to throw your [ __ ] up on our side if it
works great
cool like it doesn't need to be like
this whole stupid thing like when I
watch scatter my ashes Epidaurus and
they were talking about the whole
process of getting into a burnt dress
and if you sold in Barney's in the past
five years you're not allowed to be here
like are you kidding me
it's a [ __ ] store and if you don't
sell it I'm gonna go find it somewhere
else so you might as well [ __ ] sell
it at least have a website
but like with that said burgers and
parties so they don't carry the same
brands like I'm whatever burger dress
I'm doing like I'm so here for them yeah
they're like the only store who does
like their [ __ ] together but everything
is in like rich hipsters and that's just
not me I know either
it's like Burt it's like Bergdorf's as I
come to our store spend a ton of money
on a timeless classic piece Barney's is
like come to our store spend just as
much of money on something that's gonna
be out of style in two years I suggest
this is much money on pre dirtied
sneakers by Golden Goose oh my god I
can't with that [ __ ] I don't agree with
like people being up in arms about
golden goose like glamourizing poverty
cuz like it's just fashion and whatever
but like I just think they're ugly
sneakers and like wow five speakers that
are dirty right I'll get them dirty like
don't worry anytime I wear like all my
white sneakers are dirty so that's not
an issue but I want to buy them clean
and like be excited for a second but and
like was makeup remover wipes every time
I wear that which is right or like what
I have like these things that people use
who are like sneaker heads to put thing
on there so know if your toothbrushes
yeah and like a magic eraser by mr.
clean oh those are good those are good
but um yeah I don't understand golden
goose whatsoever me neither
anyways Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
um the other thing I want to say about
it is I'm still only on the second story
yes but the other stories are it doesn't
matter it is in New York I know a Lauren
B is going and everyone is invited
except for uh except for us maybe cuz we
talk to my [ __ ] I wouldn't want to be it
I couldn't go
yeah I had that I print a spoke about
this I mean I don't know could go if you
wanted to but you're not going to
because it goes against every that goes
even high values
yeah I agree yeah I want to go but if
you want to buy me like I feel it feel
nice know if I was invited I'll get an
answer party like they might uh send
that would be them being inclusive
like by the way I don't know the only
people that are invited are just like ah
skinny [ __ ] right yeah I don't like
something shortcut you know like whoever
who is invited is indicative of their
overall issue you know yes you know
what's so cool like since the inception
of the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
the all the shoes for the fashion show
exclusively Brian Atwood I think it's
like such a cool thing for his business
you know yeah but like is it doing that
well yeah I mean the booths are so cool
like every year it's like differ
lace-up boots it's so cool and then you
can buy them no let's go question you
can't they're like a million dollars
Swarovski crystals like hell wasn't
involved oh that's on the runway that we
can buy immediately we can't buy
anything they're wearing anyway except
like one of the thongs right dirty the
whole thing that you know sex you spiked
Candice Swanepoel
yeah do you think they dryclean it
before they gave that jumpsuit to Kylie
yes I think they everything is like
preserved like Walt Disney I can get
frozen so I'd have to see a jump suit
that fits Candice Swanepoel thank you
kindly yeah cuz Kylie as I got a real
woman's curvy body I'm not real but you
know yeah real er yeah okay next closely
very exciting something I was recently
thinking about engagements and potential
splits relationships are tested in the
Vanderpump rules Season 7 trailer did
you watch the trailer of course and then
i also read all the tweets about sheena
complaining that she wasn't ended enough
except for singing good as gold right
because we're good as gold wait that was
just reminding me of something hold on i
have to said one EEMA okay in the
meantime i'm gonna read this season
seven of Vanderpump rules is pumped full
of drama and people's got the exclusive
first look at the trailer after a season
of fractured relationships the staff had
sir seem to have come together with Jax
Taylor proposing to longtime girlfriend
Brittany Cartwright well sure had their
dramatic breakup last season quote
tonight is the night where many many of
us thought would never happen Lisa
Vanderpump says at their engagement
party of course having to throw shade at
the happiest night of their life I'm so
[ __ ] done with her I can't and I
shan't and I went and by the way there's
so much going on with her in Beverly
Hills The Reckoning oh my god we've it's
coming we've been so patient no no and
we've been talking about a potential
reckoning for overseas years had this
show and we literally like we had a
feeling it was never gonna come
no yes here we are coming he has had a
very emotional year as a few other
people here have Lisa said obviously to
remind everyone how sad they are about
Jackson Lala like just keep bringing up
negativity right and she certainly
wasn't lying the trailer teases several
fights between cast members but with la
la' can't yelling at James Kennedy's
girlfriend Raquel a marital spat between
Katie and Tom and even a revelation
about Ariana Maddux's past that being
that she had been in a relationship with
a girl says Tom Shannon woo anyways this
trailer looks amazing I was just
thinking yesterday morning I was like
what's Vanderpump girls got a premiere
we haven't even gotten a trailer it's
Ben's
so long it's been so long but like this
show is so good about fusing like social
media with the show and like we know
what's going on in their lives so it's
not like will they or won't they get
engaged but it's like how did it happen
and not only that it's like you don't
feel as like distanced from the six
months that they've been off because
they have their own version of the show
happening on Instagram right machinae
yelling at everyone on Twitter and I
could have told you that Sheena wouldn't
be in the show so much because she
hasn't been on all these trips that
they're all going on like and he hasn't
been hanging out with them it's a really
simple formula like they're all friends
so the show is based off of you hanging
out with your friends but she tried so
hard to be friends with the witches of
we know that she distanced herself from
her real friends Ariana I got a real
cell and a real self then when she
wanted to go back to who she wasn't
realized which is a WeHo like don't like
her it was too late everyone was like
you literally threw us under the bus you
can be friends with Stassi leave us
alone so now she's like caught in this
weird middle period where like she has
no friends but like she's not on
technical bad terms with anyone but now
it looks like she might be right and
then she had moved to Vegas so I'm sure
she missed a lot and she's weirdly in a
relationship with that guy Adam oh the
bartender yeah he was in the poster all
the way on the right oh wow I know I'm
so excited I'm so excited to get a
glimpse of stassi's new relationship me
too cuz they seem like a match made in
heaven like and that he's so into her
for like everything that she is like
weirdness and all like here's something
I'm gonna trick oh my god that was bad
even though Taylor Stryker who's friends
with Patrick says he swears to me he's
like nothing like that and like filming
just got the best of him and he was
being a dick the editing was being a
dick and it was just the worst of every
well until sassy like was with her new
man like I always ship turned Patrick
like I thought that they were it but now
I'm seeing like yes she's so happy she's
one of those girls who because she's
like so pretty and blonde like you just
think that she's into like the
Kardashians and like she is but like
she's also like a nerd yeah and like a
weird girl and like you just don't get
that from her so like you think Patrick
is the guy for her but like maybe beau
is the guy for her you know I think beau
is material so you see their post last
night they were like dressed up like in
crazy costumes sitting on the couch
caption necks like send kill ya know and
like I sure wouldn't have done that with
her no of course not a man isn't that
bad never never so I'm so excited for
this season Lala like the evolution much
going on there's so much going on
because she lost her father she went
brunette she went brunette her and
Randall has
get out together shot and game shows if
they getting each at the end of
everything but it's at one point in the
show she says like we need to take a
break maybe she's not talking about
Randall but I don't know I just I'm so
excited in here for it I wonder sites
gonna film I know I don't think so I
don't think so either like his teenager
in the career next season now that
they're engaged like engage it but also
and I wonder if they'd let her get away
with having a spouse who doesn't want to
be on the show because when Stassi at
especially didn't wanna be on the show
everyone was mad about it but if Stassi
spouse is giving everyone rides on
private jets like maybe they would have
shut up and maybe if Stassi spouse was
like producing gaudy right they and
taking them to can and like friends with
Scott Martin Scorsese who and apparently
Martin Scorsese watches benefi brawls
right I never thought that I would have
something happen did Martin Scorsese
yeah I'm there and also that we love
Shelter Island exactly oh is that how
most movie of the week started because
of Lala because of shelter I don't know
but we're we talking about Martin
Scorsese because of yeah we are talking
about Leonardo DiCaprio because of
something there what else and then you
were about to spoil shutter island'
shelter got it shudder shudder shudder
shudder and I was like you know what
maybe I will watch it and I did and then
everyone watched it and that's how it
anyways well I want to just quickly
segue into talking about the Lisa
Vanderpump out of it all are you done
with pump roles do anything else you
want to add I just want to add that it
seems like Raquel is getting a big like
no but it's like when all the girls are
getting along we do need someone to come
in like I do like the drop when he date
someone we need to hate someone Raquel
is stepping up to the plate and like
bringing up Lala's dad so like you know
she's [ __ ] and and I love that James
and Lala aren't friends anymore and but
here are a couple things that like we
get inundated with on Vanderpump rules
in terms of storylines and I'm not
really interested in like honestly
anything relating to Ariana like the
whole thing with her to share her hating
her vagina like what and like now it
just seems like they're really
stretching some like she made out with a
girl once you know like writers I'm
really not interested in Raquel and
James I'm really not interested in James
actually and I'm not interested in any
subsidiary characters including max
faith Kristina Kelly and I hope if I
never saw Christina Kelly again I would
be a fine person I would be a fine
person too I'm also not interested in
Katty drama knowing that their
relationships actually solid and they're
not getting a divorce like I'm
interested if they're fighting because
it's going like to a bad place like okay
I'll watch yeah but like if they're just
fighting not gonna wish them that no no
but like I just feel like they sort of
make mountains out of molehills with the
two of them where it's like they just
have like a couple spat no cuz there
used to be something there and like
there was issues like when he kissed the
girl so it's like then it was it was a
perfect formula but now it's like snot
working I have a happy marriage in Milan
oh and also Kristen seems to have gone
off the deep end the trailer ends with
lava like Kristen is drunk stands out
falls and Lala like when she leaves is
like that was so trashy and they
literally laughed out loud she's an
amazing word and I hope I don't ruin it
you know know like by saying it too
frequently no we don't say it enough I
don't think but now I agree yeah
but the banner the Illusive on
Vanderpump does Lisa Vanderpump of dog
the Lisa Vanderpump of it all so
obviously I hate her and by the way
another storyline I'm completely
uninterested in when it comes to
Vanderpump rules is blue the Lisa
Vanderpump of it all she is such the
logistics behind the plumbing at Tom Tom
like the she is such is the right word
incendiary character let's find out no
it's fine
what are you trying to say look
irrelevant oh no I think incendiary
means um that she like what is trying to
like that's and it's like negative in
sin D re irrelevant would have been like
before I look up the meaning I'm trying
I think I'm gonna guess because also we
never said our guests about Wells and
Sarah Highlands costumes like people
don't know that we actually knew it yeah
we know that yeah when we were in
Nashville Wells told us that him and
Sarah Hyland came up with the best
costume for Halloween like literally
eight months ago and he told the to us
and we thought it was so funny we told
him he wouldn't tell anyone and we did
it but then we were curious if that's
what they were actually going to do Taco
Bell and they did um a person who
commits arson no ok Liz Hyde says that
in Cindy Aries when you look starch it
well that would would that would be
correct also but but also it's also
someone who starts fire I just met like
her okay she owns the restaurant but
like it's just it's completely
irrelevant at this point her like them
go in her house like I'm pretending to
be her mentor and the her event planner
it's just so stupid and it's like I
can't suspend that much disbelief while
watching a show it's like I need to
pretend that they're still waiters and
no they're not reality turns and they
don't have nicer cars and they actually
do like okay I'll play along
but when Lisa Bennett from is getting
and they have to pretend like they're
going to paint the walls at Sur that's
where the or that like when they got
fired from serving that like they're
upset it's their life is over even
though it seems like Lisa banner up does
take away James's DJing thing which for
him is a big deal and he like is crying
good but now to the Beverly Hills of it
all like the Beverly Hills housewives
have been hanging out so much all
together without Lisa Vanderpump and she
notably was not a Camille Grammer's
wedding now there was tedious Richards
but Denise Richards was working and
she's new was working on a movie for
lifetime she's new and Erika Jayne was
on tour I need to see Denise rich earth
on hallmark yes she's got a Hallmark
face so I don't know if the Savannah
front wasn't invited didn't attend but
she wasn't there so it's important to
note also our Jimmy Smits and Kyle
Richards related I just put together
that they have the same last name I do
not think so but it's like that's so
crazy
so for Halloween all the leaders got
together and I mean all of them Camilo
was there
Denise was there everyone was there
comes dressed as Harley Quinn um Teddy
she was amazing amazing she can even
look like herself they were all there
except for Lisa Vanderpump okay I also
I'm realizing like I'm here for Teddy
like I'm Michio I'm excited to see what
she brings her sophomore season and I'm
really like I want to be here 100% for
Irene and I really hope that she lets me
I'm so heated right now in life I'm so
here frederique she's one of the few of
the house I said I actually thought on
Instagram she posted premium content
she's like so beautiful so stylish she's
living like a little furry but I'm not
mad about it
I'm not mad it still it's good
completely her and piqué are actually
they're starting a podcast together
no yeah what I just said she is her own
worst enemy she gets in her own way like
I want to like you don't want your
podcast so it's like you're on TV like
you don't need a podcast no that's like
so sad yeah no I thought about that and
it's like with podcasts it's like if you
don't have one at this point like don't
bother yeah unless you think that we got
in just under the wire before anymore
before like all the batch of people were
making podcast and it was like when we
started doing the show people have
requested that we do it as a podcast at
first we were like no we don't want to
be like a podcast like everyone has a
podcast and then we did it and like I
really I completely agree that we got in
just in time random annoying before we
like I always just think about it in
relation to where the Batchelor podcasts
were and when we started our podcast
they were I think there were like three
bachelor Palin no Caitlin had in Star
remember she came on the show in May and
she was like I'm launching a podcast
soon oh yeah so it was just like Olivia
Creedy
uh-huh and me I'm especially sei I don't
even know her original one not the I
Heart Radio one that I don't get it one
I don't even know if that was before
anyways it was like if you were a
bachelor person with a podcast like that
was like a new idea so we got in just
under the wire I just say the spent a
lipgloss smells so good smell like
honestly it's like lip smackers that's
how good it smells how delicious go to
fenty comm use code toast anyway cuz I
mean I get free product okay actually
just tasted a little bit of the lip
gloss it tastes good but like that does
taste good I love everything vending I
love everything Briana does me too
breeds me to pit again every time I
think of memes now like I think of when
I named you in the Bahamas Claudia I
hate a stars bar also I didn't hate a
star is born I had a lot of issues with
it but yeah I didn't like a star is born
hate was quicker to type we were
drinking I didn't know and it wasn't
even hit Claudia I didn't love a star is
born yeah I went to certain answer I'm
last night like of me singing but then I
realize I have too many [ __ ]
instagrams and if I need to focus on the
ones people should follow its Claude
with no job pup with no job swifty with
no job
Oh swifty with no job yeah okay she's my
passion project okay she only has 6,000
followers but it's not about it's not
about quality quantity it's really about
quality and like all of those 6,000
followers watch every video and leave
premium ask on comments here for it pop
with no job is the most under followed
person on Instagram and agree more
because get it early the most beautiful
thing in the whole world like new most
beautiful dog obviously but also the
most beautiful human and like who
wouldn't want to follow the most
beautiful human on Instagram speaking of
getting to a hundred thousand followers
should I should we do that thing that I
say I don't think so let's talk about it
after yeah because then we're not in
control of our own destiny I know we
could be oh so I brought up a star is
born because I wanted to talk about
Gillies and Rafael de la Fuente [ __ ]
nailing it the her and what Sam Sammy Jo
from dynasty put up the funniest video
first of all Liz Gillies looked so
different when she was dressed in her
custom as a man like I first I didn't
know she was and then Samuel did left
where does a being like was so funny and
by the way Brooklyn Decker commented on
their Instagram on the chose a well lol
well all around great premium content
next story Sonja Morgan says her
daughter got a near-perfect score on her
SATs Wow
Sonja Morgan's daughter Quincey Morgan
isn't your average reality TV kid she
just quote she just took her SATs and I
just I don't even want to publicize this
but it was a near-perfect score the Real
Housewives of New York star revealed on
Pharma heiress Samira Shaw's new video
podcast CeCe's father
Sonja's 88 year old ex-husband John
Adams Morgan I didn't realize that that
he's 88 me neither
John's great-grandfather founded JP
Morgan & Co and father co-founded Morgan
Stanley Sonya and John split in 2006
after nearly a decade of marriage quote
I wanted to provide for my daughter
emotional financial security and you
know no blips for her while she's
getting her education which education
for me as a woman that supports women
you know is everything Sonya decided
that Quincy won't appear on the show
quote I just don't think it's good I
mean I know how to handle it and I'll
handle myself and I choose it chose it
but I don't think I should drag anyone
else into it especially a young kid I
completely agree the way that Sonya has
like protected her daughter from the
spotlight
I felt really you're talking about this
story but I know cuz so when you put it
out there I will talk about it yeah and
like not only that the fact that she's
chosen to protect her daughter but that
everyone in the world has chosen to
respect it like I don't know what her
daughter looks like here she is she's
gorgeous
oh of course she is and now she's like
gotta go to Harvard and like she's gonna
have an Instagram and like as she should
but that's her decision right and like
good for her like if I were a daughter
of a real housewife I'd I'd want to be
on the show like cuz I'm just like
innately thirsty there's like no
daughters of Real Housewives that I feel
like do a good job of like milking the
thirst and making premium content I'm
like having a good Instagram like what
about Kyle's Victoria oh that's a bit
like Victoria I was talking about New
York more like Victoria jealous apps
like I'm not in tune so now III like
works at Morgan Stanley and like has an
amazing job and like it's not interested
in the thirst life which like good for
her but like I can't relate to that
who else like there's nobody who like is
living the life that I want like I need
like a socialite daughter but Sarah
right Kyle's daughter is totally the
perfect example but she was also like a
social he taught her before her mom was
a housewife but then I feel like the
other daughters who are in college like
they have a lot of followers for kids in
college and they post like college
photos I'm here for that yep I couldn't
agree more
who else are kids wait there was a
tangent I wanted to go on what's the
story again that we're talking about
perfect SAT score oh yeah like honestly
I love how sunny Morton like released
his piece of information that absolutely
nobody can verify like like oh if I was
like famous and I was 16 I'd be like
yeah I got a 2350 I mean SAT scores who
the [ __ ] knows that's true but we'll see
but I wish and then holla go on a
community college like yeah so but I
feel like we're even if she got like a
zero on her SATs like she could still go
to Harvard cuz like JP Morgan you know
of course actually Morgan of it all
right honestly I didn't know one day see
how college is all about connections
like of course if you know somewhat like
Evan you have to know someone yeah even
if you have the scores well you know
what's so funny that I didn't realize
until bright it's actually not funny I'm
sorry the most premium real house I've
killed r enough Instagram are the
Zolciak diamond oh my god of course I'm
saying that into a hole oh my god I'm
stinky a loyal cat how could I forget
I'm so ashamed
yeah well she does she housewife in it
and also she likes Anton the biermann's
stand out on there oh that's how good of
a job influencer yes I didn't realize
that JP Morgan the Morgan of Morgan
Stanley but JP Morgan I always thought
it was weird that there was two major
like financial institutions that both
have the name Morgan in it yeah no I
think was a merger yeah you know maybe
an acquisition right maybe they were
going going through tough times being
merged and then Sonya came along I
really need to walk the oh okay
different final story will be a quick
one oh and we just missed it because
Google employees are walking out over
sexual harassment scandals Google
employees around the world walked out of
their offices on Thursday in a global
protest over how the company deals with
sexual harassment jedem they were Google
staffers around the world walked out of
their offices at 11:10 a.m. local time
so we just missed it according to social
media posts they want changes at the
company that include an end to the use
the use of forced arbitration in cases
of harassment and discrimination sorry
what's forced arbitration may be like
for like forcing someone to like not
pursue I'm just gonna go grab what
arbitration means I think arbitration is
like giving up the claim you know oh I
think I'm just really speculating
today and this seems like a big one to
arbitration is the use of an the use of
an arbitrator are you [ __ ] kidding me
who wrote that [ __ ] arbitrate use big
to reach an authority of judgment or
settlement yeah like - yeah like they're
set they're forcing people to settle
these claims so that they don't go all
the way oh I was I was pretty much right
also next time we gotta use Bing when
looking about Google totally that is so
funny wait that's like not cool at all
especially because like I feel like
these types of like issues are so
old-school that like you would expect
this like Goldman Sachs like old-school
like fine and like where it's a boys
club but it's like Google is a new media
company they're like a spearheading
innovation pioneering all those words
like you don't expect that from this you
know yeah you don't expect that from
them like I saw the internship and
that's not what I saw I thought was that
the type of environment fostered in the
internship I didn't see any forced
arbitration in the internship but I just
don't expect this one like a new wave
media company like a millennial Gen X
vibe no totally and they're so
progressive and like every other element
that it's like this seems like an easy
an easy thing just to not like have
issues like this you know yes do the
right thing don't force people to
arbitrate no it's like I hate what I'm
making forth to arbitrate no I truly
hate it the show has really expanded my
vocabulary my vocabulary my knowledge I
would have never known that Google
employees walked out around the world
either and it also like in looking
because you wonder why Google's not
letting those search results pop up
totally imagine being in charge of your
own search results uh I wish it's like
every time Google's someone Google - Kim
Kardashian like Instagram , forward
slash girl with no job would come up you
know totally in you couldn't pay for
that I said well not I gotta get a
Kinect at Google if you ask believe
receive manifest destiny if you work at
Google and can help me with my search
results like help me that's a good one
also if you work at Google like and
you're back in the office I wonder how
long the walkout lasted right and
honestly like I feel like if I had a
traditional job and there were walkouts
I can't even for causes I didn't believe
and like I would just join have to work
let's go
yeah maybe why are we still standing
here hungry death we haven't switched to
carbon paper walk out like every times I
mean bother you hit the walk I'm in the
bath and I we are still using
walk out yeah by the way what should we
should have a walk out right now oh my
god except well this is the most fair
and balanced workplace in New York no
totally just some women-owned businesses
then took that key walk out thank you so
much for joining us today the morning
totes the Millennial morning show we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on Facebook and YouTube
after Thanksgiving though we are
strictly going on YouTube so make sure
you hop over there we are working on our
skip issue are squishy o so just hold on
and stop complaining I'm big begging of
you it's YouTube salt which makes a
Google salt yeah and it's because
everyone is too busy walking out walk
out there's a glitch at the beginning of
the morning toes walk out I am headed to
Charlotte Nashville Miami and Alabama
Birmingham Alabama those my final four
shows of the year so make sure you've
had your girl with no job comp to get
tickets Nashville is sold out some of
the Charlotte shows are sold out but you
can pretty much get tickets to most of
them before they're gone please do that
I can't wait to meet all of you that's
it
anything you want to promote and be
thirsty for always can follow me at
rakia problems for the most premium of
content I can't think of my life right
now and like my oh and my birthday's
coming up next week so like just keep
the greatest gift is the gift of a
follow at the morning toast we're so
close to a hundred thousand and we're
gonna do like something nature I don't
know what if something major add a
hundred thousand like something [ __ ]
huge yeah can't wait and we're gonna
actually do it not like then no we've
done everything that we've said you did
your hundred layers of hairspray oh my
god and that was torturous almost died
back to end we still said when we get to
10,000 patrons we're gonna throw a party
for the toasters oh yeah and we're gonna
do we're not a trio but when we get
there I I remember we're gonna throw it
for all the toasters are just once we
pay a month figure out the logistics um
but I remember and you did say when we
you get on a plane and you get off in
any land just goodbye everyone having a
J
you